[Music]
first appearing in super street fighter
two turbo as a secret boss Akuma remains
one of the most powerful characters in
the street fighting universe unlike Ryu
and Ken he embraces the killing intent
of the SAT suit no had go
[Music]
is
I
vodka Akuma's V skill is a single hit
Perry that could be cancelled into a
palm strike or launching kick his
v-trigger changes the properties of some
of his special moves giving him a double
air fireball and a more devastating
Dragon Punch
a comb is standing medium kick be skill
launching kick and light hurricane kick
can be cancelled into each other in
rapid succession this is an important
technique to learn as it builds V gauge
while allowing for a combo extension
sucio
he may have less health and his show
tube Reverend but Akuma benefits from a
more versatile tool set he can stage
fiendish resets with his classic demon
flip and when the bases are fully loaded
he can make the opponent paid dearly for
even the slightest mistake
[Music]